what are your favorite
three
hip-hop
albums of all time oh man this is
something that uh wu-tang forever okay
midnight marauders very nice yeah and
either late registration or graduation
but that's off the top i mean we played
registration over graduation yeah we
have these arguments with people and
there's i mean i'm leaving i mean we got
reasonable doubt we got illmatic we got
i mean there's a million you know
lifestyles of the poor and dangerous
from l like i could go on and on for
lifestyles of the poor dangerous over
the big picture
um wait which one had casualties of a
dice game on it that was the big picture
yeah that that's my favorite outfit yeah
okay you know and and the funny thing
about that is like as incredible as
those records were i mean they were
awesome and it was in the essence of
like the golden raw hip-hop that was
just boom bap album to the fullest and
even that album was like put together
like kind of it was out it came out
after he died yeah it was kind of pc it
wasn't necessarily like it yeah but i
mean incredible it was amazing i
actually met fat joe the other day and
uh because i was at mtv doing rap fix or
whatever and i brought up the enemy
which is a song that he has with him and
big o and that's my favorite fat joe
verse of all time and i was like
reciting his lyrics i was kind of fanboy
and i was like yo that joe is the truth
he's cool yeah people always fat joe has
got like the illest hip-hop roots like
the crates
so uh tonight you are doing your thing
it's going down at uh martini ranch yes
uh do you i know you got your your click
visionary music group right yes um talk
about like because i'm not as familiar
with the the whole crew yeah yeah about
the crew man well visionary music group
was started um
by chris aru who's my manager and my
best friend he's the president of
visionary's group uh and me and him got
together a couple years ago had the same
vision you know he taught me a lot of
things about the business i taught him a
lot of things about the artistry um the
only other artist on visionary music
group is uh john billion who's a singer
also from he's from new york city but we
live in l.a together me and all the
homies we got we called the vmg house
and um i mean there's a bunch of homies
just even in the rat pack there's castro
there's uh you know who's on tour with
me right now is uh quest the homie
skizzy mars but i mean it's a big it's a
big group man from gravity who shoots
all my visuals to six who's my in-house
producer like there's a lot of a lot of
guys man you know in that that that
really make this happen like the young
tde so i heard you say that it's like
the new rockefeller yeah
yeah definitely that's how i perceive it
and you know once again by no means i
mean rockefeller is the rock like at the
end of the day they're them but i'm just
saying in this new generation i like to
call it the second renaissance of
hip-hop definitely i feel like you know
visionary um is definitely gonna be be
something great as soon as we continue
to do what we're doing and also develop
more talent in the future so we're just
taking it day by day
man anything else you want to tell the
people out there yeah follow me on
twitter at logic301 that's logic301 as
you see same on instagram yeah straight
up 100 and uh go download the new
mixtape welcome forever please enjoy it
stay uh peaceful nothing but love and
positivity there it is logic in the
building man it's power ninety eight
point three
thanks man
of course